it's time to bring you some of the
stories that are the talk of the table
this morning michelle what you got i got
something great my talk at the table is
a special in-person commencement
ceremony for harvard school of public
health this weekend's event was for
students who graduated during the
pandemic and the keynote speaker is a
very familiar face cbs news chief
medical correspondent john lapooka
dressed the graduates he shared stories
from his career as a physician and a
journalist and the lessons he's learned
including his version of the key to
success
no matter what hat i am wearing i've
come to understand that no credential in
any field
is as crucial to success
as the ability to experience and
practice
empathy empathy is your superpower
it's your superpower
he says that all the time dr lopez also
told the graduates there will be tough
times ahead but they have chosen a
career that can bring them great joy i
also want to give a shout out to sam
fernival who is dr john lapook's medical
producer's
son amy birnbaum a long cbs news
producer and sammy graduated from
harvard law school there it is let me
say this about john lepuc john lepuc
teaching you about empathy is like
sinatra teaching you how to sing
there is none better there are no more
deeply empathic human being walking the
earth he is the salt doctor is a gem
indeed yeah and he's a great doctor too
i have to say good to have him here at
tbsp yes